hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar
understanding and managing challenging
samples in your laboratory
i'm iva maria zoman product manager for
northern europe
at ortho clinical diagnostics and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational webinar is brought
to you by lab roots
and sponsored by ortho clinical
diagnostics
essay interferences are a common problem
in the laboratory
creating a disconnect between the test
results and the clinical reality
interferences force the lab to
investigate to handle samples as
exceptions
which interrupts the workflow and
creates a delay in the test results
in today's webinar our speakers will
address
and discuss the effect of common
endogenous interferences
on different clinical chemistry analytes
i would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation you can
report your problem
by clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
for a complete biography on all our
presenters today
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our first
presenters dr rachel marrington
and finley mckenzie from birmingham
quality uk nicholas
rachel and finlay will present the
results of a recent study
which looks at the effect of hemolysis
ignorance and leukemia
on the measurement of several common
biochemistry analytes across different
platforms
rachel and findlay you may now begin
your presentations
thank you very much eva and thank you
very much to ortho
for inviting us to present our work this
afternoon with you
now my name is rachel marrington i'm the
deputy director at birmingham quality
which is part of university hospital
birmingham nhs foundation trust
and part of uk kneecrafts now
there's a list of the declarations that
vinnie and i
have affiliated with on the screen i'm
not going to go through them now
what we would like to talk to you about
today is really to get you to think more
about your specimens
what they look like and the composition
of them and how these could affect
clinical results which you are reporting
now a little bit of background i'm not
going to go into too much detail
but when we're talking about serum
indices
we're talking about hemolyzed specimens
now when a specimen is hemolysed
this is the red color that you see and
this is
the hemoglobin um from within the cells
that has leached out into the serum or
the plasma
and this might be because of the cells
then the
serum has been on the cells for a
prolonged period of time
or there may have been some problem
during collection
um the tourniquet may have been too
tight the wrong gauge needles used
but either way the contents of the cells
as well as
including the hemoglobin have leaked out
and made the serum or plasma
red and it is the heme that the iron in
the heme that is giving this red colour
now icterus did when specimens look a
yellow or a green
tinge to them and this is because of
the an elevated bilirubin within the
specimen
of you most frequently see this in liver
disease
um but the important thing to note here
it's not just the color yellow that
could be affecting any
spectrophotometric acids
it's also the bilirubin can interfere
with acids that use hydrogen peroxidase
and can actually cause a false decrease
in results so you could um
be misreporting in some athletes that
use hydrogen peroxidase
and if you have an elevated igteras
index
now the final one indices that we look
at is lipenia or turbidimentary
now when you have an increased
concentration of lipoprotein particles
you get light scratch scattering in
and spectrophotometric assays and also
this does cause
some problems with indirect ises because
of the space that is occupied
with the lipoproteins that are used
now as we'll come on to a little bit
more detail later on how we make the
specimens
we use intralipid in our lypemia
specimens
and that's a very concentrated emulsion
so it isn't a true reflection of
lipoprotein particles
but it does it helps in terms of the
color but it doesn't help in terms of
the space occupying
what you would have with like zip it's
now
just for reference i'm showing you what
the absorbance spectrum
looked like for hemolysis for igtiris
and for lipemia it's just this is just
really
so that you can have an idea of the
wavelengths that are used and
any spectrophotometric assay would be
affected
if it is um looking at the wavelength
which um were their absorbance maxima
for the hemolysis
or the bilirubin or the lipemia
now really before we start because i
think how much of a problem
actually is this now what i have here is
some workload
from one of our local hospitals that has
about
50 um general practice workloads and
it's 50
hospital workload and it really is i was
just looking at
what over a week what percentage of
samples
they had a hemolysis arcturus and
lipemia above
say two grams per liter for hemolysis
and
and igteras was 100 micromoles per liter
and mipmu one millimole per liter
so this low levels of serum indices and
it's affecting a low level of work
but depending on your workload this
could actually
impact quite a lot of patients having to
be re-bled
or being mismanaged
so our uk newcast for clinical chemistry
scheme is served to approximately 500
or 550 participants and last year we
conducted an audit
to actually look to see how many of
those participants measure serum indices
and whether they measure them only on
their chemistry platform
or also on their immunoassay platforms
i think 97 of our participants do
measure serum indices but 85 percent of
those do
measure indices on both their chemistry
and immunoassay platforms
now what was interesting was 33 of
participants
apply the same serum indices to other
assays using the same
sample elsewhere in the laboratory now
this is really important because what
we'll be coming
on to in a few minutes is looking at the
applicability
of indices that have been measured on
one platform
to other manufacturers platforms now
interestingly only 13 percent of
participants
back in 2019 measures any form of
internal quality control on their serum
indices
now i am the scheme organizer of the uk
necrosma serum indices eqa scheme
this is a scheme that is iso 17043
accredited and it has been operating
since 2017.
now all of our material is made in-house
it is not commercially sourced now we
either distribute material in its native
form
so with endogenous hemolysis um icturus
and lipemia
or we add in hemolysate bilirubin or
intralipid
and that is the case for the specimens
that we have made for project quibble
which finley will be discussing
later now this distributes three
specimens monthly for analysis
of hemolysis icturus and lipemia and we
also have something called analyte
x now this is a different analyte every
month
and we ask participants to measure this
to look at the impact
of hemolysis upturism lipemia on
the that's the concentration of that
analyte
that our scheme can handle indices and
categories
we'll only be looking at the indices
today as that is
the um form that ortho results are
produced in
but and our target value that we use is
the manufacturer
mean i've just included for reference
here the scheme units that we use
we know that many different participants
report
so now we'll analyze and report in
different scheme units to this but
this is what the data will be shown in
now if we first
look at the hemolysis index this is one
of our classic
um scheme report report designs for our
schemes
we have three specimens that have been
distributed and it's a recent
distribution
and on this occasion all the specimens
had some degree of hemolysis
the specimen b has some bitter ribbon
added and vitamin c had some intralipid
added as well you can see from the
histogram
how um the different participants have
performed
there's more detailed information um in
the table on the left
and you can see that this participant
has done very well they've got a green
traffic light against all of their
results
but what is probably more important is
actually looking to see
how hemolysis and compares between the
manufacturers
especially if you are going to be moving
your um samples between different
platforms
and on this graph it's all the data that
we have collected
over the last three years and looking at
the homologous index for the different
manufacturers
and we're comparing it to the rush um
hemolysis index
now i want to be very clear we're not
saying that rush
is the correct um result it's the target
value
it is just that is the most populous
method and we have to have something
that we're comparing to
so in this case i hope you agree there
is good agreement between
all of the major manufacturers on the
hemolysis
indexes that they are producing now
if we
if we move on to icturus
um once again it's a similar graph i'm
not showing you the report format on
this
this is just looking at the
data from the last three years you will
see
at first sight you might say there's not
good agreement between all the
manufacturers
and i probably should point out that the
pink dots here are those for ortha
and they are giving lower results
alongside abbott
compared to say siemens and the rush but
once again we're not saying rush is
correct siemens are correct
we don't know who is correct everybody
is individual and this is because
different wavelengths are
used to calculate the igterest indices
but what is interesting to note if you
look really closely there are some
diamonds um on the identity
line and if you look at the pink
diamonds they overlay
the same diamonds for the siemens
for the rash for their abbot and this is
where we've actually added in
unconjugated bilirubin now
we predominantly use conjugated
bilirubin
because it is water soluble and it means
that we don't have to add any organic
solvents
into our specimens which could cause
other problems
but when we have added unconjugated
bilirubin in
we do see very good agreement between
the manufacturers
now the little insert on this slide
shows that there is a two nanometer
absorbance wavelength maximum difference
for the conjugated and the unconjugated
ribbon and this is a well-known
um phenomenon it isn't just something
with our specimens
now and likewise your patient specimens
will be
a mixture of conjugated and unconjugated
bilirubins that will be contributing to
the icturus
so you really do need to bear this in
mind that perhaps the igteros index
isn't quite as transferable between
manufacturers
if we just come on to lypemia now
this lypemia is a little bit more
different
difficult to think about that we have
lipoproteins
present or in our case majority is
infra-lipid
and these do separate out just like a
patient sample would
our eqa samples separate out as well now
we ask
our participants to mix the specimens
thoroughly
and before they analyze them but we do
see a lot of variation which is what
we're seeing here
between the different manufacturers once
again
we don't know who's right or who's wrong
it's just saying there is a lot of
variation with
lypemic specimens and this certainly
will hold
true with your clinical specimens too
but once it has been separated if
they've been left to stand
for a while they will start to separate
out so if you go and then analyze them
the glyphic index that you originally
measured will not reflect
the adequate sample that you've taken
for analysis
if they have separated
now just finally before we move on to
project quibble i want to quickly
show you analyte x now using the same
distribution that i showed earlier this
happens to be total protein
the picture on the right hand side other
as a
picture of the three specimens we
actually sent out
i think you'll agree they just look red
they're all at the same degree of red
and from the naked even from the eyes
you can't actually tell there's any
difference
now i haven't gone through the report
but there were differences that
the um was detected and lypemia was
detected
but if you just look at the histograms
it's the same
axis of on the x-axis you just need to
look at the spread of the data
there's no need to actually look at the
individual methods on this
you can see all participants there has
been a
change as the specimen has gone from
just being hemolyzed
to slightly ectoic and this is a very
low level which
you would could normally get and to
being slightly glyphic you're getting a
big difference in the total protein
result now i'm not going to make any
further comments on
that but i'm just going to move on to my
final slide now before handing over and
it's
we also asked participants whether they
would
report that result based on the indices
that they have seen
now all i want you to gain from this is
that there are three specimens that have
three very different
serum indices but the different
specimens look
the same there's the the pie charts
which
the green is would you report it yes the
red is would you report it
no they look the same every participant
would have
reported the specimens the same really
um
whether they were going to report them
yes or no but as i'll show you if you
remember from the previous slide
there was a big difference in the total
proteins
seen between the specimens so i'm just
going to leave you with that
and then um finley is going to go into
more detail with project quibble for you
in a minute
thank you
hello i'm finlay mckenzie i want to
quickly tell you about
project quibble which was the acronym
we've got for
quantifying indices in biochemistry
laboratories
the objective of this little project was
to investigate the impact
of different concentrations of hil
indices on a number of clinical
chemistry analytes
across a lot or all across a range of
major diagnostic manufacturers platforms
at the same time so it wasn't just ortho
analyzers we were looking at we're
looking at the all of the major players
now this study was taken in the last
quarter of 2020
and it's key to note that it was not an
eqa scheme it was a one-off
snapshot of where we were
now what we did we covered a range of
clinical chemistry
and cardiac analytes and then same time
we looked at some endocrinology and
inflammation
but essentially we're talking about 39
different analytes
and for each of those 39 analytes we
were
looking at hemolysis
ectarus and lydemia so we've got about
120 different
graphs and tables i could show you i'm
not going to show you all today
but i am going to touch on some some key
examples of the type of things we can
we can show and the rest of the data
will be available in due course
so what we sent out was uh 11 different
specimens
a base at the beginning of the end three
levels of hemolysis
three levels of electricity and three
levels of glycemia
and the samples were made in-house by
ourselves and as rachel had said
the way we make these samples is not to
try and get the
color and the cell contents but we don't
have the
the space uh considerations that you
would see in a clinical specimen for say
measuring high lipid in an uh direct ise
we don't cover that
it's really more the the color and the
content we're looking at
so to that end i'm quickly going to show
a few slides that are all the same
format there's a red part hemolysis
yellow hectarus and the blue for lipemia
this was just looking at the
impact of the different the different
manufacturers
on the uh the increased values
the scales here are quite generous so it
looks here just to the
to the uninitiated all of the all of the
major players do have
an issue with the readiness that you get
with with hemolysis
but i'll pass quickly onto the one that
most people consider
um to really the key analyte when
looking at hemolysis in particular
because not only have you got the red
color you've got the leakage of the cell
contents so the potassium
levels do rise they rise because the
intracellular potassium is released
into the serum and we can see here that
all of the manufacturers get
impacted in in one way or another
the key thing nowadays is looking at
error budgets
and this is the way that lots of people
now across
that the the professions international
the eqa providers
we're all looking at describing things
in terms of a total error budget
and again you can look at it in terms of
uncertainty measurement as well
so it's the same thing for coming at it
from a different angle but what we're
looking at then
for any test that you do you want uh
you've got a component
of the error budget through with what
how biased your asset might be
what the imprecision of the essay might
be and other uncertainties
that add together to form the total
error and the indices form part of this
other uncertainty
so if we look at the impact of hemolysis
on potassium for example
there's a couple of sources you could
look at to see what the the experts are
saying
so looking at total error the eflm
database
is looking at a total error of 4.8
percent and that's based on
biological variation which is probably
the best approach to do
the clia and the birmingham quality uk
equals are both taking
information back from proficiency
testing or eqa schemes
and one of the the papers is quoting the
clear as being
plus or minus 0.3 millimoles per liter
and the birmingham quality
is coming out as 3.2 total error
which at a potassium of six equates to
about
0.2 millimoles per liter these are
actually quite tight limits
but if we look at
what actually happens in in real samples
this is
the first graph that i'm showing is from
the ortho systems and this is looking at
the
apparent rise of or the real rise of
potassium
when the hemolysis is between
two three four fives and eight and
essentially what we're seeing is for
a a rise of
one gram per liter of hemolysis equates
to
0.3 millimoles per liter of potassium
and looking at this second graph here
this is taken from
an audit that we did over participants
looking to see what cutoffs they
actually used
and again the different colours are what
the manufacturers recommend
and also recommend a limit of 0.5
and in that case that eats up about half
of their error budget in in hemolysis
but if you just look at the range of
colors some of the green people are a
very low level but most of the greens
are in the middle somewhere
some of these red ones are at quite high
levels so the message from this
is that different manufacturers
recommend different levels
but on top of that the laboratories
themselves will choose
whether or not to take the advice of the
manufacturer
quickly looking at creatinine which is
one of my favorite analytes
i've done a lot of work on this over the
years so there's a couple of things to
look at
the first thing to look at in with a
mollusc is that you can get
an impact in either direction you can
get some methods
you get an increase in percentage bias
and in some methods you get a decrease
in percentage bias some methods of
no increase at all and again just for
the recording
i'll say luckily here we've got auto but
behaving reasonably well here in
in the middle but there are other things
that go on
there's uh in the presence of billy
rubin
you will get a decrease in apparent
creatinine from some of the jaffa
methods
and again the lypemia tends to be
relatively flat
and some of this noise as rachel said
might be to do with specimen mixing at
the end but certainly at the low level
like pms that doesn't appear to be an
impact
i suppose i'm concerned about creating
because
the values that you get from that do
feed into aki and gfr calculations
and even a very small difference in
absolute numbers
and natural bias and creatinine does
make a big impact on
patient pathways
this is a some graphs from the troponins
now i'm
indebted to my colleague alan reid in
glasgow who helped us
with this service but looking at this
the hemolysis again is probably the
thing
you would be worrying about most of all
in real life situation
getting blood from someone who
apparently has a heart attack
so you have a situation here where most
of the
the methods have a decrease in apparent
troponin
in fact the the ortho system is a slight
increase
and i suppose if you are going to have a
an effect perhaps the
the more fail-safe system would be to
have a slight positive rather than
missing things with a a slight unlock
negative
and again just for the record these are
the the different
um components high sensors with
troponins
and the toner eye and troponin t
as we know that's a single manufacturer
so in conclusion then i think the key
things
that come out mostly from rachel's
presentation is that serum indices are
in desperate need for some form of
harmonization
the hemolysis rate is something that
laboratories can have an active role in
influencing
you there will be in vivo hemolysis
which you can't do anything about but
most of the things to do with transport
timing separation of samples that is
something a laboratory should be
should be having an active role in doing
steering industry scheme looks at what's
going on and it really
has fed in a hell of a lot of good
information into the the evidence space
to see where we are with these uh
with these assays we are continuing to
work with the european groups
and the final message is the fact that
although
off label lots of laboratories will be
measuring
some basic biochemistry and fluids like
like uh
acidic fluid and plural fluid and when
in those situations these samples do
come in a variety of colors there's
green with red ones and brown ones and
things so you need to make sure
you can check this too so the conclusion
is it's a big problem for us and we're
getting a good handle on it now
and something like the uconnect quest
for hl il indices
helps a long way in this thank you
thank you both for this great
presentation i'd like to now introduce
our next speaker
natalie mully principal clinical
scientist at the royal marston nhs
foundation trust natalie will talk about
the electrolyte exclusion effect
and the advantages of using direct iron
selective electrode-based technology
and its importance when analyzing
samples from cancer patients
natalie the floor is yours thank you
very much eva and good afternoon
everybody
my name is natalie mully and as eva said
i'm a
principal clinical biochemist at the
royal mars and nhs foundation trust
hospital
and today i will be talking as part of
the managing challenging samples webinar
about the electrolyte exclusion effect
that is associated with the use of
indirect iron selective electrodes or
ise
and then i will go on to talk a little
bit about the use of
direct ises and how their use benefits
us and our patient population here at
the royal marston
so i will just start off by giving a
little bit of background about
both our hospital and our biochemistry
service
so the royal marsden is a specialist
cancer hospital
and we treat over 59 000 nhs and private
patients each year
we cover a range of oncological
conditions and we actually have
dedicated
units for all cancer types in addition
to that
the royal marsden is also a national
institute for
health research biomedical research
center for cancer
and we also have close ties with the
institute of cancer
the trust itself currently operates
across three locations
there's two main sites these are chelsea
and london
and there's another site in sutton in
surrey
and a few weeks ago we recently opened
up a third site which is a new
private treatment and diagnostic center
in central london
and across those three sites we have we
actually have a dedicated
biochemistry laboratory service on each
of those three sites
in terms of our equipment that we have
across these three sites
we have four vitros 5600 analyzers
two of these are located at the saturn
site and two of these over at the
chelsea site
and we do predominantly dry slide
chemistry and also immunoassay on these
analyzers
we also have one vitros xd 3400
and that is a chemistry analyzer and one
vitros eciq analyzer
and that's at the new lab that we opened
a few weeks ago
in terms of our workload we do around
175
000 une requests per year so that would
roughly equate to what you would say
would be our routine automated
biochemistry workload
so compared to larger labs with um a
large gp population
and workload that might not sound like a
lot
um but one aspect that's fairly unique
to our service here at the marsden and
biochemistry
is that we have very rapid turnaround
time targets
so our published turnaround time targets
are 90
within three hours however we have two
further
aspirational turnaround targets and
these are that we aim to get 90 percent
of our routine sample results out within
90 minutes
and 60 percent of our routine sample
results out within 60 minutes so those
would be things like our lfts
and une tests and these might sound like
quite strict targets but actually these
are targets that we
we do actually meet we quite often do
meet these aspirational targets
in addition to our routine automated lab
we also have a
dedicated protein section and
in this section we do around about 7 000
protein electrophoresis requests per
year
and the majority of these patients upon
referral to us
are they're usually already known or
suspected to have a hematological
malignancy
and so patients with a condition called
multiple myeloma
make up quite a large proportion of our
case load of work within this section
and because we have a lot of patients
with multiple myeloma as part of our
workload
many of these patients will have the
presence of a paraprotein within their
blood
and as a result of this they will have
raised total protein results
and that's important to note because i'm
going to come on to talk about this more
in the context of electrolyte
measurement
so in terms of measuring electrolytes in
the laboratory
most high throughput labs will measure
sodium and potassium
routinely using iron selective
electrodes
or ises there are two types of ises that
are commonly used
these are direct ises and these use
undiluted sample of the electrode
surface
and the other type of ises are commonly
used are indirect ises
and these use samples which have been
diluted using a suitable buffer
prior to analysis
so when we are thinking about sodium we
know that it's the predominant cation in
the extracellular fluid
and we know that its main function is
involved in the maintenance of fluid and
electrolyte homeostasis
and the reference range will vary very
slightly um depending on the method you
use in the
patient population that you have but
it's usually around 135 to 145
millimoles per liter
and hyponatremia which we would define
as a sodium of less than 135 moles per
liter
is the commonly most commonly seen
electrolyte disorder and
particularly within hospital in patients
and when we are considering the
investigation of hyponatremia
or a low sodium the method of
measurement with consideration to direct
and indirect ises is an important factor
in a differential diagnosis
the underlying cause of hyponatremia as
you'll see from
the algorithm that i've put on this
slide is commonly investigated
by both assessing the fluid status of
the patient and then putting that into
context of the plasma
and urine sodium measurements and
osmolality
additionally as part of this
investigation at the top of the tree on
the left hand side
it's important to also initially exclude
spurious causes of low sodium
and this occurs due to analytical error
secondary to either razor lipids
or raised proteins and that can result
in the electrolyte exclusion effect
which i will come on to talk about now
so the electrolyte exclusion effect
results in pseudohyponatremia
aka a falsely low or falsely normal
sodium measurement so essentially it's
an underestimate
of what the true sodium result would
actually be
and a typical pattern would be we would
see in this case you would have a low
measured plasma or serum sodium results
but the osmolality measurement would be
what you would say would be normal or
iso osmolar
um and that would be around 275 to 295
million per kilogram
and the electrolyte exclusion effect is
an analytical phenomena
and that occurs with electrolyte
measurement with indirect ifcs
specifically
and the reason this happens is because
prior to analysis the sample undergoes a
dilution step
and in doing so there is an assumption
that is made
that the plasma is approximately 93
water
and the electrolytes are present within
that aqueous phase
and about 7 solids so that would be your
proteins and your lipids
however some patient samples
actually have increased proteins or
lipids and so because of this a fraction
of that aqueous
space is replaced and so that assumption
that the plasma is 93
water actually no longer holds true and
this schematic that i put up here is
used to illustrate
how the use of indirect ises can result
in the electrolyte exclusion effect and
therefore
pseudohyponatremia so there's two tubes
here
and the sodium concentration in both
tubes is actually normal
at 140 millimoles per liter but the tube
on the left hand side
represents a normal sample with the
typical portions of the solid and plasma
water phases
so that'll be the 93 aqueous and the
seven percent non-aqueous phases
but on the right hand side you can see
that the tube has a higher percentage of
solid phase
as would be seen in hyperlipidemia or
hypoprotinemia
when i indirect ises are are measured
before they are measured they undergo
dilution so in this example i've
i've put they've undergone a one in ten
dilution by the automated analyzer
so what happens is in the right hand
side tube
the sodium per liter of total plasma is
lower
and so the dilution leads to an
underestimate of the sodium that is
measured after the dilution step
and so in the example that i put up here
what we actually end up with
is a measurement of 112 millimoles per
liter
um if you if you suspect
pseudohyponatremia or a falsely low
sodium result
um what you can do is you can
overcome this and you can get a more
accurate result by measuring sodium
using a
direct ise method and this can either be
a blood gas analyzer
or alternatively an automated analyzer
which uses a direct ise method
and that's what we use at the raw master
we use the ortho and slide
and this excludes pseudohyponatremia
because there is no dilution step
prior to analysis
on this slide you can see a schematic
of what the direct ise method looks like
by the ortho technology each slide
contains
two ises or iron selective electrodes
and these contain an ionophore which is
methylmensin
and also on the slide you can see there
is a reference layer
a silver layer and a silver chloride
layer which is coated on a polyester
support
and how this works is um some patient
sample
and some electrolyte reference fluid
are applied to the slide on separate
half and fluid migrates towards the
center of that paper bridge that you can
see
and that forms a stable liquid junction
and that connects the reference
electrode to the sample electrode
and then each of those electrodes will
produce an electrochemical potential
and that in response to the activity of
the sodium and the potential difference
between
those two electrodes will be
proportional to the sodium concentration
in the sample
and as there is no dilution of the
sample this method is not prone to
pseudohyponatremia
as you will see with indirect ifc
measurements
so use of direct isc methodology is
important in our patient population
as i mentioned earlier we have a large
myeloma caseload
i actually looked in our lab system
to see how many total proteins we
requested between march 2019 and march
2020
during that time period we had
approximately 6000
reported total protein results in that
time frame
around 600 of those were actually above
the reference range of 82 grams per
liter
so that's around 10 of our samples
and our highest total protein result
during that time period was actually 139
grams per liter
so you can see we do get very high um
total protein results in our patient
population
and i just thought i would use some um
patient results to illustrate
um the electrolyte exclusion effect and
pseudohyponatremia
um both sets of results on this slide
actually belong to the same patient
on the left hand side you can see our
old method
and we use an indirect ifc measurement
for
around that time period and on the right
hand side you can see where we'll be
using the
also direct ise method so the patient
on both of their blood samples had a
very similar raised
total protein results of around 126
grams per liter
and in both cases unfortunately had a
very large power protein of greater than
50 grams per liter
however you can see with the old method
that the sodium actually falls below the
reference range at 133 millimoles per
liter
and on the right when we transitioned
over to also flight
direct ise method the sodium is actually
within the normal range
this would be a typical kind of pattern
that you would see
and this this example may represent
pseudohyponatremia due to the
electrolyte exclusion effect
another area we have found also to be
uh beneficial in the dry slides um to
our patients in terms of improving their
clinical care
is their ability to be able to provide
results even in the presence of
hyperlipidemia
or raised lipids as you can as you would
expect
a lot of our patients who are actually
on chemotherapy medication
and this can't be administered usually
until the routine by chemistry such as
the urea and electrolytes and liver
function tests
have been seen by pharmacy and if you
look at the
the results on the left hand side with
our old method you can see that most of
the results have been
knocked out due to leukemia the only
thing we were able to report was the
lipid profile
and if you look on the right hand
side you can see this patient has a very
similar lipid profile
the triglycerides are 9.8 millimoles per
liter in both case
however with the dry slide method we
were not only able to report out the
sodium results and lipid profile but
actually we were able to
report out the full profile of requested
tests
and the reason for this is because um
the microscope
technology that's used in the dry site
methods actually acts to filter out
endogenous sample interference this is
really important because if we can't
provide
results this could potentially lead to
delays and chemotherapy being
administered
so just to round off really so
why direct ise and slide methodology in
general is beneficial for us
so as i've previously alluded to we have
a relatively large proportion of raised
total proteins due to the nature of our
our workload um and that could and these
would be patients who would be
potentially prone to the electrolyte
exclusion effect and pseudohyponatremia
due to their very raised total protein
results
however um we also see
a reduced effect of lipemia not just in
our electrolyte measurements but
actually
all our all of our other assays um so
you can see on the the left hand side
i've put up a table which shows some of
the lypemic index thresholds that which
results would be knocked out at by the
also
dry slide methods and you can see most
of these are around 800
for leukemia index and to put that
number 800 into context if there was no
interference um from lipids in the
sample this would be
less than 20. um
while we are a small lab compared to
other centers in terms of numbers of
samples that we process each year as i
i mentioned earlier we do have very
tight turnaround times
the aim for us is to minimize long waits
for our patients
in having their chemotherapy prescribed
and i think that's even more important
in the context
of the pandemic and our patient
population who might be enemy
compromised ideally we don't want them
spending more time in the hospital than
they need to
and there are several factors that i've
mentioned that help us to meet our
tight turnaround times but one of the
things that helps us is the stable iqc
performance for our iron selective
electrode test so sodium and potassium
we are qc is very stable we are rarely
delayed in processing samples because we
don't need to spend time troubleshooting
failed
internal quality control so once we get
our qc on the analyzer and it's
it's out and it's within 2sd we can just
get on and process those samples
we don't see any drifts throughout the
day week or month really in our
iqc performance and we very rarely need
to calibrate
it can actually be up to six months in
between
calibrations potentially the main things
that would cause us to recalibrate would
be
if we are changing lot number of slides
or if we were changing
the number of electronic reference fluid
but otherwise you know it can be several
months
um between needing to calibrate
so just uh conclude the learning points
of my talk and the main points
so there are two types of ises that are
commonly used these are direct ifes
which use undiluted sample at the
electrode surface
and indirect ises and these are samples
we use a sample that has been diluted
using a suitable buffer
a falsely low or normal sodium result
can be obtained due to an analytical
phenomenon which can occur when
measuring sodium
by indirect ises and this occurs due to
pathological states of hyperproteinemia
or hyperlipidemia
where the assumption that the sample is
93 water
no longer holds true and this is what we
call the electrolyte exclusion effect
pseudohyponatremia due to the
electrolyte exclusion effect
can be resolved using direct irc
measurements such as the ortho method
that we use at the marsden
or by blood gas analysis
use of these methods allow us to meet
our rapid turnaround times
negate the requirement and time taken to
exclude pseudohyponatremia
and also improve the reliability of our
sodium results
thank you very much for your time
thank you natalie this is really
interesting last but not least
i would like to introduce els melis emea
senior marketing manager for clinical
labs essays
at auto clinical diagnostics who will
give us an overview on how vigils
technology can help
minimize the impact of interferences
else you may now begin your presentation
thank you eva and good afternoon
everyone
um both previous presentations were
highlighting the challenge of
very common interferences now in the
next few minutes
i will give you a brief overview of how
in-vitrous technologies from ortho
can help minimize the impact of
interferences
so as examples of common interferences
both hemolysis ectorus and lypenia
as well as electrolyte exclusion effect
were already called out but there are
so much more possible interferences as
you can see here on this slide
just to name a few what about impact of
water quality
or paraprotein interference or risk for
carryover
all of these challenges may have an
impact on the patient results and in
some cases
they may even lead to misdiagnosis or to
further investigations
about why results would not match the
clinical picture of the patient
if we look at the literature and focus
on the incidence of hil
or of power proteins in specific patient
groups
or if we look at the incidence of hypo
or hypernatremia
in acute care patients or cancer
patients
the risk for an erroneous result is real
actually based on literature
investigation
up to five percent of clinical
laboratory test results
may potentially be impacted this of
course
uh we have to add is depending on the
type of samples that you
will get in the laboratory but the risk
is real
however there is a solution to this
there is good news of course
um to minimize the impact of
interferences
what we have at ortho or six unique
vitros technologies which are the core
of divitrox analyzers
and in the next few slides i will give
you a few examples of how these help
you in delivering high quality results
so let's start with the first one this
example
is about microsite technology and
actually we have
three formats and natalie she
just presented already about the second
one about the potentiometric slide
where we use direct ise technology
however most chemistry essays are using
the first one the colorimetric principle
so let me talk about that now
with the colorimetric microslide we
actually have
multiple layers in which the reaction
takes place
and for some essays we would add even
extra layers
to trap potential interference what i
want to call out in this slide
on the left side specifically is a key
function of the first layer which is the
spreading layer
this layer does not only evenly spread
the few micro liters of sample on the
slide
but it also captures potential
interferences like hemoglobin
or lipids and since we measure
reflected light and the reflection for
most essays occurs
underneath the spreading layer the
substances are not interfering
with the results to this use of dry
chemistry
in the slide format is therefore
different and more secure
compared to wet chemistry systems which
which you see on the right side where
reflected
refracted i'm sorry light passes
through the liquids and also through the
interfering
substances
so in other words the challenge of hil
is strongly reduced
and often completely avoided actually by
the use of the spreading layer in the
microslides
and for our homogeneous and
heterogeneous immunoassays we have
another technology
vitros micro sensor which cannot avoid
the interference but will measure the
potential impact
by using the death volume of the sample
and then flag the result if needed
let's look at another challenge the
potential impact of paraproteins
many case studies as you can see some
examples listed here
they have been published about incorrect
results
due to paraproteins with wet chemistry
but again here with the spreading layer
the para paraprotein gets
captured and does not interfere in the
reaction or the reading
let's look at another challenge for
instance the impact
of that water quality again here
multiple publications are available
about the potential impact of impurities
in the water
which may lead to false results and with
vitros
we do not need external water just all
we need is a plug
so no concern about water impurities
and one more example before coming to a
close
what about the challenge of bubbles
clots or carryover
for this we have the vitro's intellitech
technology
and what that does for you is that the
aspirational sample
is done through a patented pressure
level sensing technology
which would rather report an error when
there is a bubble or a cloth
instead of giving a false results and
finally
thanks to the use of disposable tips we
can also 100
exclude the risk for carryover
so in summary interferences are a true
challenge in the lab
but thanks to the built-in safety checks
of the vitro's technologies we can avoid
or strongly minimize the potential
impact to the patient's results
and deliver high quality essays
with this i thank you very much for your
attention
and i hand it back over to you eva thank
you
thank you very much else i would like to
open up the follow for questions now
if you have a question you like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for today
so let's get started our first question
is for finlay and rachel
indices have no unit as the measurement
is rather qualitative
rather than quantitative you use units
which means
that you have indices really in
quantitative values
how to calculate the indices into
quantitative values
okay thank you yes so we either
see in the indices of qualitative and
they're recorded as a category
now i didn't actually show that data in
the presentation
but there are a couple of manufacturers
that do use categories so that's like a
category one plus two plus three plus
or there is a semi-quantitative indices
as
what we have shown here and it's these
semi-quantitative indices
that are loosely correlated to you
with units and with analytes so with
here hemolysis
um that is loosely cholera correlated to
hemoglobin
and the scheme unit that we use is grams
per liter but
different manufacturers will have
different units there's grams per liter
milligrams per deciliter and micro moles
per liter
and we can use conversion factors to go
in between those
with a bit of rubin and victorious
that's loosely correlated with bitter
rubin
and there's a couple of units in use
there and micromoles per liter and
milligrams per deciliter
and for lipenia this is loosely
correlated to a triglyceride
concentration
and the units that we have there are
millimoles per liter
grams per liter or milligrams per
deciliter now the interesting thing here
is the conversion between millimoles per
liter and grams per liter is only a
factor of about 1.1 1.2 i can't remember
off the top of my head
so they are very similar now i have got
a nice slide which i haven't got to show
you at the minute
that all manufacturers have then their
customers
reporting results in a mixed reporting
results for measuring their indices in a
mixture of these
and what's really important for you as a
laboratory user
is to know how your instrument has been
set up and then
your middleware or however wherever you
interpret these units in relation to the
test
that you're measuring you have to have
the same
cut-off values that have been put in we
have known of laboratories
that have will be measuring in one unit
but applying
the hemolysis index from a different
unit so obviously
they don't that doesn't work you need to
happy in the same
units so thank you problem
thank you rachel thank you we have
another question for
natalie in fact uh when switching from
indirect to direct ise percentage twice
how many more results were you able to
report
it's hard to um to give a fam number on
this
but what i would say is um we we
practically never
um knock out or don't report um urea and
electrolytes due to interference
from um lypemia with our current methyl
method because
the threshold as i went through my
presentation
is very high so it's yeah it doesn't
happen
um in practice where we're not able to
report um with our current method
great thank you very much natalie um we
have time for
one more question this is for uh nicoise
could you provide a brief summary on the
outcome of the kibble project as a whole
anything the audience should be
particularly aware of or like a takeaway
message okay thank you and so i
think this is a very good project we are
indebted to everybody that
who contributed to this work we have a
lot of data
and we're still processing the raw data
and but our initial
results our initial review of it shows
that on a whole
all manufacturers are affected by
indices of
hemolysis interiors and lipimia to some
degree in some of the assays
now what we also did and data i haven't
shown here is we asked laboratories
what cutoff they use for a particular
assay for the hemolysis pictures and
lipemia
now i haven't presented this data but we
know from our routine scheme
that there is a wide variation so i
think the main cut off
the main take-home message from this
really is
that there are there's such a wide
variation in hemolysis interiors and
myopia cutoffs that are being used
both with them within the different
laboratories different manufacturers
so therefore this will affect the
reporting of patient results
in your hospital and the region that
you're working in as well
so that is something that i think when
the whole
laboratory community needs to take away
and look at
um so that there is a better evidence
base and a bit
better way forward for everybody
great thanks good go ahead tonight
so i was just thinking one of the
messages is that the material that we
made for the project it because of the
large volumes we were using because we
were dealing with
100 participants with 40 odd analytes at
three different levels of each of the
indices
so in order to make that material
there's a few compromises in there so
although i think we did mention our
presentation that
we certainly saw the impact of the
the cell content and the color but we
didn't
because of the way the specimens were
made we wouldn't show all of the good
work that natalie showed we didn't have
that impact on the on the electrolyte
results
we also know that some of the some of
the findings that we've seen
we've we have managed to reproduce with
other materials but it doesn't always
exactly fit in what you see in real life
the troponin data that is showed
although we've seen that
on other occasions we've made specimens
like this
we think that perhaps the the vitro
system also shows up a slight negative
bias
whereas on the data we had it was
slightly positive so there are
little caveats around around the edges
but by and large
the messages is fairly strong i think
great thank you very much for the good
summary and that concludes today's
session before we go i'd like to thank
the speakers
and audience for joining us today
questions we did not have time for and
those submitted during the on demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
author's purpose is to improve and save
lives through diagnostics because every
test is the life
for more information about also please
visit our website at
orthoclinicaldiagnostics.com
you can also view the webinar on demand
and leverage will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
stay healthy and safe and we're looking
forward to seeing you at one of our next
webinars
take care bye